merci euh de votre présence madame la
chef de l'Office antistupéfiant on vous
laissera présenter les personnes qui
vous
accompagne
excusez-nous très sincèrement pour ce
retard à l'allumage on avait la police
les douan et on terminera par la
gendarmerie notre mission a commencé
théoriquement formellement le le le 8
novembre elle s'achève le 8 mai donc on
a quelques mois sur un sujet qui est
très vaste et ces premières auditions de
ce jour nous permettent un peu de de
poser le décor euh donc on n'est pas
totalement euh ignorantf sans savoir ce
qu'il ce qu'il recoure comme réalité
mais peut-être nous aider à à préciser
euh les contours plus plus pointus que
nous donnerons à cetteette commission
d'enquête euh je dois euh vous rappeler
quelques formalités euh juridiques qui
ne sont pas accessoires un faut
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passiv des peines
prévues aux articles 434-13 434-14 et
434-15 du code pénal et je vous invite
chacune et chacun d'entre vous qui
prendrait la parole à prêter serement de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
à lever la main droite et D et dire je
le
jure VO donc si chacun peut le faire et
je sais pas qui qui participera au bon
très bien et ben c'est parfait voilà
cette formalité est en remplie ce que je
vous propose c'est que on vous laisse
ouvrir sur la base du questionnaire et
d'un propos assez général un quart
d'heure 20 minutes et puis après on vous
abvera d'un feu roulant de
question merci monsieur le président
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs euh avant de
avant de démarrer donc vous présenter
les personnes les personnes qui
m'accompagne mon adjoint Christian
Christian doroini également contrôleur
général mais magistrat de l'ordre
judiciaire détaché dans un emploi de
contrôleur général ce qui est une un
positionnement assez peu assez peu
classique au sein au sein du ministère
de l'Intérieur madame Sophie Étienne qui
est commandant divisionnaire et et qui
est chargé de la coordination et de la
synthèse au sein de l'OFAS c'est et qui
est accompagné également de Monsieur
Hugo Darbois qui est un de ses
collaborateurs et donc qui participe
évidemment à la préparation de ces de
ces exercice euh un propos liminaire un
propos liminaire mesdames et messieurs
mon intervention s'inscrit bien
évidemment en complément de celle du
directeur général qui est intervenue en
en tout début d'après-midi et je
souhaita souhaitais vraiment à titre
liminire vous communiquer non pas des
chiffres pour vous
assiner une litanie de chiffres mais
bien poser les choses et le trafic de
stupéfiants puisque c'est le c'est la
question dans un contexte dans un
contexte un petit peu plus global et
quelques chiffres clé me semble me
semble absolument nécessaire le trafic
de stupéfiant le directeur général l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure c'est le premier
marché criminel au monde il représente
un chiffre d'affaires évalué en France à
3 milliards d'euros 30 milliards d'euros
pour pour l'Europe on estime aujourd'hui
à 21000 le nombre d'emplois temps plein
générés par les trafics de stupéfiants
et à 240000 le nombre de personnes qui
en France vivent directement ou
indirectement de ces trafics en 10ans
les saisis de cocaïne ont été multiplié
par 5 avec presque 28 tonnes saisies en
2022 dont 75 % sur sur le vecteur
maritime et puis les saisies de cannabis
quant à elle ont été multiplié par 2
avec 128 tonnes saisies en
2022 ce sont 111 millions d'avoirs
criminels qui ont été saisis en matière
d'infraction à la législation sur les
stupéfiants soit 13 % du total des
avoirs criminels saisis C ces saisis ont
été multiplié par 2 en 10 ans alors il
faut mettre en regard de ces chiffres
ceux de la production 2300 tonnes de
cocaïne produite en 2021 soit une
multiplication par 2 en 10 ans pour
mémoire les trois pays producteurs sont
la Colombie la Bolivie et le Pérou ceux
des saisis des ports de nos ports
voisins des ports voisins euh à ceux de
la France ceux d'enverse et de Rotterdam
sont les plus emblématiques avec
respectivement 110 tonnes et 50 tonnes
saisies en 2022 dans chacun de ces dans
chacun de ses ports les chiffre encore
de la consommation en France 5 millions
de consommateurs 5 millions d'usagers
dont 1,2 million d'usagers réguliers de
cannabis et 600000 usagers annuels de
cocaïne ceux des violences criminelles
75 règlements de compte entre malfaiteur
depuis le début de l'année 2023 en
sachant que entre 80 et 90 % de ces
règlements de compte sont liés au trafic
de stupéfiants je n'y reviens pas le
directeur général l'a développé tout à
l'heure dernier chiffre celui des
saisies d'armes euh en augmentation de
10 % en 2022 avec plus de 8000 armes
saisies et là encore une proportion 25 %
des armes saisies le son à l'occasion
d'enquête pour trafic de stupéfiants
alors j'articulerai mon propos en en
quatre quatre quatre points euh le
premier qui est celui de la menace en
rebalayant rapidement euh quelques
points qui me semble essentiel sur sur
cet état de la menace la deuxième partie
sur la Rost qui est apportée à ce face à
cette menace un bilan de la politique
publique mise en œuvre depuis depuis
2000 depuis 2019 et puis bien sûr des
perspectives puisque c'est ça qui qui
qui nous intéresse alors l'état de la
menace en matière de trafic de
stupéfiants en France et en Europe
puisque je crois qu'on peut pas regarder
la France juste à travers nos frontières
il faut qu'on ait un regard beaucoup
plus global et cette menace est un
niveau historiquement élevé elle
s'illustre à travers trois constats le
premier de ces constats les produits
stupéfiants sont présents en quantité
importantes sur le territoire national
et européen la France est au carrefour
des trafics en raison de son
positionnement géographique elle est
bien s on est bien sûr à proximité des
zones euh de production des pays
producteurs nous sommes également euh
une zone de rebond pour euh pour
certains trafics je pense notamment à la
zone antiguyane euh globalement
aujourd'hui en France aucun territoire
n'est épargné par les trafics le sujet
majeur de préoccupation aujourd'hui est
celui de de la cocaïne ça a été
largement largement abordé par le
directeur général ce n'est pas là encore
une préoccupation qui est purement
française c'est une préoccupation qui
est européenne alors dans un contexte
d'intensification du trafic
transatlantique la cocaïne arrive
massivement dans l'Union européenne par
les ports principalement les ports
d'Europe du Nord ce que j'ai cité tout à
l'heure en vous donnant des chiffres
extrêmement significatifs donc envers et
au Rotterdam à titre de comparaison au
havrees cette année ce en 2022 pardon ce
sont un peu plus de 11 tonnes qui ont
été qui ont été saisies par par les
services principalement de de la
douane alors la France est à la fois une
zone de rebond donc zone antiguyane et
une porte d'entrée par ces ports et ses
aéroports cet engouement pour la cocaïne
est bien sûr lié au niveau de
consommation en France 600000 usagers
annuels je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
mais c'est également lié à un facteur
économique extrêmement important et la
rentabilité de ce produit pour les
organisations
criminelles juste pour euh illustrer
cela
aujourd'hui 1 kg de cocaïne euh en
France hexagonale s'achète entre 28000
et 30000 € donc prix au kilo il est
revendu au gram entre 65 € et0 et 70
€. alors bien sûr les organisations
criminelles sont opportunistes et elles
recherchent du profit c'est leur c'est
leur raison d'être euh donc voilà sur le
le le produit sur la cocaïne ce que ce
que je souhaitais vous dire l'héroïne
euh redevient un sujet d'attention
puisque les saisies euh d'héroïnes en
France ont augmenté ces dernières années
particulièrement en 2022 avec un peu
plus d'une tonne 4 de de saisis c'est un
produit qui est moins consommé mais qui
reste mais qui reste présent sur le
marché et pour lequel euh on doit avoir
une attention particulière notamment en
raison de la situation en Afghanistan et
puis avec la route des Balcans qui est
la route traditionnelle de euh de de
d'importation de ce produit aujourd'hui
les consommateurs se tournent de plus en
plus vers les drog de synthèse euh ce
qu'on appelle les produits de synthèse
avec les opioïdes de synthèse les
cannabinoïdes de synthèse produits qui
présentent des taux de toxicité
extrêmement élevés puisqu'on le voit
également dans les études notamment de
l'OFDT ou même de l'OEDT au niveau
européen les consommateurs sont à la
recherche de produits aux effet de plus
en plus fort on recense aujourd'hui en
France 365 nouveaux produits de synthèse
différents euh petit petit focus
toutefois euh puisque tout à l'heure
dans une des questions vous avez évoqué
le fintanil la France n'est aujourd'hui
pas touché par le fantanil comme les
États-Unis peuvent l'être néanmoins ça
ça reste un sujet d'attention vraiment
très très important et notamment en
terme sanitair puisque on sait les
dégâts que que cause le fanil aux
États-Unis on constate donc l'émergence
de nouveaux marchés et des organisations
criminelles qui s'adaptent et se
diversifi en permanence les trafiquants
sont généralement polyproduits on a eu
des trafiquants qui sont passés de la
résine de cannabis ou de l'herbe de
cannabis à la cocaïne avec un taux de
rentabilité comme je vous l'indiquais un
peu plus haut beaucoup plus élevé les
trafics en France sont à la fois le fait
d'organisation criminell français et de
groupes criminels étrangers implantés en
France je crois qu'il faut vraiment
avoir à l'esprit qu'on est face à des
organisations criminelles qui sont
décloisonnées qui sont opportunistes et
qui qui recherchent les moyens de de
travailler ensemble et les moyens de
s'associer et c'est souvent le cas avec
des des rencontres qui parfois ont lieu
à
l'étranger les organisations criminelles
tentent en toutes circonstan de déjouer
les contrôle on le constate avec
l'émergence de laboratoire sur le
territoire européen alors avec des
démantellements qui ont eu lieu
notamment en Espagne euh peu de cas pour
l'instant identifiés en France mais des
points d'attention sur du produit
importé et à transformer avec la
Colombie qui exporte également ces
chimistes donc ça ce sont des points
d'attention particulier et puis ce
phénomène de laboratoire il faut l'avoir
à l'esprit pour tout ce qui est tout ce
qui tourne autour des drogues de
synthèse puisque on le sait au Pays-Bas
ou en Belgique les produits sont
transformés sur sur le territoire
deuxème moyen de contournement des des
des contrôles le phénomène des dropof
qu'on observe également depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois avec des
transbordements en mer avec de la
cocaïne qui vient s'échouer sur sur les
côtes sur les côtes françaises alors
plutôt manche mer du Nord mais mais
également en en Atlantique euh donc là
encore euh c'est une adaptation des
organisations criminelles face au
renforcement des contrôles qui ont été
opérés dans les ports au niveau français
bien sûr mais aussi au niveau européen
puisqu'il y a eu un
travail en coalition avec nos
partenaires européens pour renforcer ces
contrôles dans les ports le deuxième
constat dans cette dans cet état de la
menace les violences criminelles en lien
avec les trafics de stupéfiants sont en
augmentation très significative en
France le directeur général l'a évoqué
tout à l'heure les rivalités de
territoire les concurrences entre
organisations crimin
conduisent aussi au développement des
violences criminelles qui sont
inhérentes à ces trafics on l'a vu tout
à l'heure dans dans ma présentation sur
les chiffres l'augmentation des armes
saisies conduit inévitablement à une
augmentation des violences alors
qu'entend-on par violence criminel ce
sont bien sûr les règlements de compte
les h les homicides volontaires les
tentatives d'homicide et aussi les
enlèvements séquestration qu'il ne faut
pas qu'il ne faut pas oublier dans cette
dans cette comptabilisation les auteurs
et les victimes de ces violences
criminelles sont aujourd'hui de plus en
plus jeunes on parle notamment des
petites mains des trafics mais ces
violences peuvent aussi toucher des
victimes collatérales sans aucun lien
avec les trafics on a eu des événements
extrêmement malheureux en France l'été
dernier et puis le weekend dernier à à
Dijon alors ces violences criminelles
sont généralement sous-traité à des
équipes mandatées pour agir recruté
généralement sur les réseaux sociaux et
notamment je pense à des phénomènes de
recrutement de tueurs à gage à à travers
les à travers les réseaux sociaux
troisème constat la corruption
euh le phénomène de la corruption est de
plus en plus révélé et çaavère être un
véritable outil des trafics de
stupéfiants mais j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure c'est un outil plus globalement
de la criminalité organisée puisque de
toute façon les trafics de stupéfiants s
s sont compris dans un ensemble plus
large que celui de la criminalité
organisée sans la corruption qu'elle
soit publique ou privée les trafics ne
prospèrent pas ça peut toucher bien
évidemment euh des personnels dans les
ports et les aéroports qui vont
faciliter le passage de la marchandise
ou le ou ou la sortie du produit euh de
d'un port ou d'un d'un aéroport euh ça
peut toucher des agents publics des
policiers des gendarmes des douaniers
des greffiers aucune euh aucune
profession n'est épargnée euh dès lors
que vous avez euh des
euh des euh des trafiquants qui offrent
des somme d'argent extrêmement
conséquente vous pourrez avoir euh à un
moment donné euh des personnels qui euh
qui vont répondre à l'appel à l'appel de
de ces sirènes
criminelles alors face à cette menace la
France a adapté il y a presque 4 ans son
dispositif de lutte contre les trafics
de stupéfiants notamment en favorisant
la l'approche globale alors la première
étape passait par une meilleure
coordination des acteurs et une
structuration du
dispositif le DGPN vous l' vous l'a dit
beaucoup d'acteurs luttent contre les
trafics au sein de la police nationale
au sein du minist ministère de
l'Intérieur et des outrmèes au sein du
ministère de l'économie et des finances
vous entendiez la directrice générale
des douanes au sein du ministère de la
Justice également il y a 4 ans c'est le
besoin de coordination de ces acteurs
qui a été pointé c'est l'ambition du
plan national de lutte contre les
stupéfiants du 17 septembre 2019 cette
politique publique avait besoin d'un
acteur central pour la porter alors sur
le modèle du chef de file en matière de
lutte contre la la la le terrorisme qui
est la DGSI l'ofast toute proportion
gardée puisque la DGSI est une direction
générale et et et compte un nombre de de
de personnel beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
importants donc l'OFAS c'est le chef de
fil de la lutte contre contre les
trafics de stupéfiants fruit d'une
réforme entrée en vigueur le 1er janvier
2020 l'ofast c'est un service à compéten
nationale SCN rattaché à la Direction
nationales de la police judiciaire la
dnpj et bien sûr la DGPN l'OFAS dispose
unee structure centrale 220 220
personnels dont la composition est très
interministérielle je vous présente mon
adjoint tout à l'heure donc magistrat de
l'ordre judiciaire détaché dans dans un
emploi deôleur général c'est aussi bien
sûr la police la gendarmerie la douane
euh le renseignement pénitentiaire parce
que quand on parle de la justice c'est
vrai qu'on parle on pense tout de suite
à mon adjoint mais il y a également le
renseignement pénitentiaire et ça c'est
un point clé pour pour l'ofast euh la DG
FIP puisque on parlera du volet
financier euh des des trafics et il est
très important de pouvoir travailler
avec les services de la DG FIB sur ces
sujets-là bien sûr des personnels
administratifs et des contractuels
j'insiste sur les contractuels puisque
nous avons besoin aussi de compétences
spécifiques dans ce type de structure en
terme d'analyse en terme de coopération
internationale et de connaissance des
mécanismes euh et donc il est très très
important de pouvoir avoir recours à ces
personnels alors l'idée à l'époque était
de recouper enfin il y a 4 ans était de
regrouper sous une même autorité des
compétences des savoir-faire qui jusqu'à
présent relevaient de plusieurs
administrations au niveau territoriale
l'auface compte 24 implantations
territoriales 14 antennes et 10
détachements en hexagone et en outr-mer
mobilisant un peu plus de 550
personnels nous avons déployé également
104 cellules de renseignement
opérationnel sur les stupéfiants les
cross une dans chaque département
regroupant au niveau des territoires là
aussi policiers gendarmes et douiniers
avec pour objectif de décloisonner le
partage de de l'information le le le
croisement du renseignement l'auace
centrale est organisée en trois pôles je
ne vais pas vous les détailler
simplement euh vous les les résumer en
en en trois mots donc trois grandes
missions comprendre cibler agir les
trois pôles de l'ofast c'est le pôle
stratégie c'est le pôle renseignement et
c'est le pôle opérationnel le pôle
stratégie c'est la connaissance des
trafics quelle est la menace à laquelle
on fait face quelle analyse on produit
autour de cette menace quelle stratégie
on déploie en terme de coopération
international c'est extrêmement
important de pouvoir le euh le le le euh
l'organiser au niveau au niveau central
le renseignement c'est l'une des
avancées majeures de la création de
l'OFAS c'est le développement des
missions de renseignement de ce service
à compétence nationale l'ofast est un
service de renseignement du second
cercle comme nombre de services de la
dnpj et ça c'est très très important
dans le cadre des des perspectives
notamment à développer la mission
opérationnelle elle est beaucoup plus
classique ce sont la c'est la conduite
bien sûr d'enquête judiciaire s sous
l'autorité des magistrats nous
travaillons principalement avec les virs
et au premier rang desquels bien sûr je
place la junalco juridiction spécialisée
pour travailler sur le tout à fait le
haut de du spectre et le les les têtes
de fil du des
trafic alors après avoir mis en place
les structures la seconde étape
nécessitait de repenser les méthodes
également développer la mission de
renseignement j'en parlais à l'instant
et favoriser l'approche globale d'abord
développer la mission renseignement la
particularité de l'eoface comme je vous
l'indiquais c'est d'avoir la double
casquette service de poli judiciaire et
service de renseignement du second
cercle l'ofast exerce son rôle de
coordination avec les acteurs du monde
du renseignement il s'agit d'actionner
de nouveaux capteurs de renseignement
avec pour objectif l'entrave l'entrave
du produit l'entrave des individus
l'entrave des organisations criminelles
l'offace est également un acteur de la
de la doctrine du renseignement criminel
de
2021 nos activités dans ce dans ce cadre
sont couvertes par le secret de la
défense nationale et donc je je ne
développerai pas plus avant aujourd'hui
cette ce sujet d'une manière générale il
s'agit de multiplier les capteurs au
plus près des territoires avec les cross
jusqu'à l'international nous avons des
dispositifs qui fonctionnent et qui sont
uniques les unités permanentes de
renseignement en Espagne et en Caraïb ce
qui nous permet de de de projeter des
des effectifs de l'offaste sur ces zones
et puis une équipe dédiée en Colombie
qui est pilotée par notre attaché de
sécurité intérieurs en poste en Colombie
et qui là aussi permet de faciliter les
liens et de conduire des enquêtes avec
les autorités colombiennes alors que
signifie favoriser l'approche globale
l'approche globale impose de ne pas
limiter l'action des services à la seule
interception des flux et je pense que
quand on on parle de lutte contre les
trafics de stupéfiants on ne peut pas
effectivement se contenter de saisir du
produit on le sait ce n'est pas l'effet
attendu ça permet de sortir du marché un
certain nombre
de des quantités non non négligeables de
produits mais ce n'est pas suffisant
pour démanteler en en profondeur les
organisations les organisations
criminelles donc pour les démentanteler
ces organisations criminelles
euh on doit définir une stratégie autour
des cibles d'intérêts prioritaires on on
a défini une une stratégie autour des
cybles d'intérêts prioritaires les
identifier et les entraver donc où
qu'ell soi en France comme à l'étranger
nous avons eu plusieurs plusieurs
réussites
significatives depuis depuis la mise en
place de aste avec 22 22 Cies d'intérêts
prioritaires qui ont été qui ont été
interceptés euh notre rôle est aussi
d'analyser les violences criminelles
l'approche l'approche globale c'est ça
c'est d'analyser violen criminelles en
lien avec les trafics de stupéfiants les
enlèvements les séquestrations les
homicides et les tentatives d'homicides
et leur lien avec les trafics et puis
enfin bien sûr l'approche globale c'est
lutter contre les flux financiers liés
au trafic de stupéfiants le blanchiment
alors la corruption on n'est pas
forcément sur du flux financier à
proprement à proprement parler même si
euh ils en génèent inévitablement et
puis bien sûr le dernier volet c'est
celui de la saisie des avoirs criminels
l'approche globale nécessite enfin et
aussi de prendre en compte la dimension
internationale des trafics au plan
opérationnel mais également au plan
stratégique avec la définition de
priorités stratégiques je vous le disais
en introduction cette coopération elle
est à la fois bilatérale et
multilatérale multilatérale j'ai à
l'esprit bien évidemment les liens que
nous avons avec Europol qui sont
extrêmement forts euh à la fois en
participant au cycle politique d'Europol
et puis à toutes les task forces
opérationnelles piloté par par l'agence
européenne et qui concerne qui concerne
bien sûr la
France Quel bilan tiré de cette
politique publique mise en œuvre depuis
depuis 4 ans le plan national de lutte
contre les trafics de stupéfiants à 4
ans si il avait il comportait 6 axes et
55 mesures dont un grand nombre a déjà
été a déjà été mis en œuvre le plan de
2019 a permis la mise en place des
structures notamment l'ofast son réseau
territorial le réseau des cellules de
renseignement opérationnel sur les
stupéfiants les cross des outils ont été
créés carofast la cartographie la
cartographie des points de Deal le
directeur général en a parlé le fichier
des objectifs qui permet aussi de faire
de la déconfliction avec nos services
partenaires notamment les services les
services de la douane les services de la
gendarmerie la mise en place du portail
de signalement qui permet euh à tout
particulier de pouvoir signaler un
trafic y compris is de manière anonyme
pour préserver son identité la doctr une
doctrine a été posée permettant à chaque
acteur de connaître son positionnement
et puis une feuille de route
internationale a été établie et mise à
jour annuellement le deuxième temps de
cette politique publique est de toujours
Mobil mobiliser pardon davantage
d'acteurs en interministériel à tous les
niveaux au plus près des territoires
pour prendre en compte la réalité des
trafics qui pourrissent la vie des
habitants jusqu'à l'international donc
avec la coopération internationale bien
sûr avec les zones de production le
renseignement maritime qui est un
élément central en matière de lutte
contre les trafics de stupéfiants et
puis l'action européenne qui est
conduite qui est conduite dans les ports
afin de maintenir une dynamique la
refondte de ce plan s'est avéré
indispensable le plan national remagné
et qui est en cours de validation reste
guidé par les mêmes impératifs d'origine
beaucoup d'interministérialité et
s'appuie bien sûr sur l'état de la
menace qui est élaboré par l'ofast et
euh qui sortira également vous avez une
première édition de cet état de la
menace en 2021 et la version 2023 et est
sur le point de sur le point de de
paraître également résolument
interministériel euh ce futur plan
fédère l'ensemble des administrations et
des forces compétentes en la matière il
regroupe de nouveaux acteurs euh que
l'on compte aujourd'hui que l'on
comptera parmi les les contributeurs
bien sûr des services de renseignement
mais mais je je ne vais pas plus avant
le secrétaire le secrétariat général de
la mer et la mission nationale de de
contrôle des précurseurs chimiques
puisque quand on parle de drogue de
synthèse il est extrêmement important de
pouvoir s'intéresser à la composition de
ces drogues de synthèse cette cette
feuille de route rénovée met l'accent
sur la la criminalité connexe au trafic
de stupéfiants les violences criminelles
la corruption et le volet financier des
des trafics avec bien sûr une dimension
internationale extrêmement poussée le
point sur lequel je souhaite insister
c'est aussi la N nité que cette
politique publique s'inscrive dans des
politiques publiques également beaucoup
plus larges la dimension santé publique
la dimension sanitaire que le
DGPN a exprimé tout à l'heure le volet
préventif tout ça est impératif pour
lutter contre lutter contre les trafics
et les prévenir puisque et ça c'est le
rôle de la mil desk puisque le le le
ministère de l'Intérieur et des outres
mèr ne peut pas être le seul acteur en
matière en matière de
stupéfiant dernier point celui des
perspectives et j'en aurais j'en aurais
fini avec mon propos
introductif beaucoup de défis à relever
encore même si le plan à 4 ans je crois
qu'il faut être il faut être
extrêmement extrêmement humble à la fois
lucide et humble face à la menace à
laquelle à laquelle on fait
face les défis s'inscrivent dans un
cadre plus global que celui des trafics
de stupéfiants bien c'est mais bien
celui de la criminalité ité organisé
dont la direction nationale de la police
judiciaire est l'acteur majeur alors
première catégorie de défis des défis
numériques bien sûr avec les réseaux
sociaux qui servent à la fois de vitrine
pour le commerce de la drogue mais aussi
des vecteurs de communication pour pour
les organisations criminelles pour les
trafiquants on recrute aujourd'hui de la
main d'œuvre sur les réseaux sociaux et
je pense que ce point-là est extrêmement
important euh même si nous avons
développé les investigations sur les
réseaux sociaux je pense que il faut
encore aller au-delà de ce qui a de ce
qui a été mis en en place deuxème
catégorie de défi des défis
technologiques le directeur général tout
à l'heure a parlé de des
cryptoomonnaaies des cryptoactifs le
blanchiment à travers ces à travers ces
outils doit être au cœur de nos
préoccupations on doit aussi faire
évoluer euh nos modes de travail
aujourd'hui c'est c'est ces avoirs là
sont sais sont saisissables et sont
saisis par par les services les
messageries chif chiffré euh on a tous
en tête deux noms de messagerie chiffré
qui ont qui ont donné lieu à un
important travail de la France c'est
encrechat et skyoccc ce sont des
messageries utilisées par les groupes
criminels quasiment exclusivement
utilisé par les groupes criminels et
notre rôle c'est d'être toujours euh en
avance de phase et d'essayer de d'être
positionné sur le nouvel outil utilisé
par les organisations criminelles
notre objectif c'est aussi de lutter
contre les contreemesures qui sont
posées par par les les organisations
criminelles une cargaison de cocaïne
aujourd'hui elle est piégée elle a des
balises posées par les organisations
criminelles qui veulent savoir où se
situe où situe leurs produits y compris
quand il est dans un container en pleine
mer et qui fait une traversée
transatlantique donc tous ces défisl on
doit on doit y faire face et les
services doivent s'adapter un défi li à
a donné sa captation sa conservation son
traitement et son analyse c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très très important
notamment quand je reprends le sujet des
messageries crypté quand on voit le
volume de la donnée que les services ont
à traiter aujourd'hui un défi en terme
de communication et
notamment la déconstruction de l'image
positive des trafics de stupéfiants qui
est un sujet extrêmement important et
qui sera un enjeu central comment à
travers la communication mon que
l'entrée dans les trafics n'est pas
quelque chose de positif et n'est pas
une solution de vie comment casser
l'image de l'argent facile et que
l'ascension sociale ne peut se faire par
le crime ça fait partie des enjeux
extrêmement importants auquels il faut
réfléchir en termees de communication
notamment le dernier défi c'est un défi
juridique
évidemment avec on a toujours besoin de
plus d'outils bien évidemment dans le
cadre des des missions qui sont les
nôtres des évolutions législ le DGPN
vous a vous a évoqué ces sujets un
service de renseignement a besoin de
d'outils pour
travailler aujourd'hui les services de
la la dnpj sont second cercle du
renseignement en revanche ne dispose pas
du je dirais d'un fichier propre à un
service de renseignement c'est-à-dire
que on n pas complètement tiré les
conséquences de du statut de service de
renseignement de des services de des
services de la dnpj et pour ce qui me
concerne de de l'offaste et je crois que
quand on développe cette mission de
renseignement et c'est ce qu'on a fait
au sein de l'ofast en spécialisant un
pôle en cloisonnant déjà les missions de
de ce pôle renseignement et en en le en
le spécialisant pour pouvoir échanger
lui-même avec des services de
renseignement premier et second cercle
il est très important de pouvoir
disposer d'outils adaptés notamment de
croisement de la donnée là je je ne
parle pas de base d'analyse sérielle ou
de logiciel de rapprochement judiciaire
où les cadres juridiques sont prévus
mais bien d'une base de données en
renseignement il est très important
qu'en matière qu'en matière de
criminalité
organisée on
raisonne au-delà du dossier judiciaire
il faut qu'on ait une vision beaucoup
plus générale pour pouvoir anticiper les
phénomènes
comme comme c'est fait aujourd'hui en
matière de en matière de terrorisme et
je crois que pendant trop longtemps on a
eu une vision quasi exclusivement
judiciaire de la criminalité organisée
aujourd'hui les exemples y compris de
nos proches voisins européens avec des
des menaces envers des institutions des
menaces envers des journalistes des
menaces envers des meurtres sur des
journalistes et des avocats doit nous
conduire à réfléchir autrement face à
cette
menace deème 2è euh proposition piste
autour de la corruption notamment euh
c'est un outil de la criminalité
organisée je vous le je vous le disais
tout à l'heure euh néanmoins
elle est indispensable cette corruption
euh aux organisations criminelles pour
pour prospérer on le voit nos ces
d'intérêt prioritaires ont des capacités
corruptrices extrêmement importante en
revanche la corruption est tra est
souvent traitée à part euh elle dispose
de certaines techniques spéciales
d'enquête euh qui sont propres à la
criminalité organisée mais le régime de
garde à vue de 96h n'est pas applicable
y compris quand vous avez euh je vais
donner un exemple un dockur ou un
personnel un personnel dans un aéroport
complice d'une sortie ce n'est pas la la
la qualification de corruption qui sera
retenue on sera plutôt sur la complicité
de trafic alors qu'on aurait intérêt à
bien identifier ça comme comme un fait
de de corruption d'ailleurs en matière
de corruption en en infralégislatif on a
également des pistes des pistes de
travail autour de la formation pour
lutter contre le le recrutement criminel
ce que les Pays-Bas ont fait avec
notamment les personnels des ports je
pense que c'est ce sont des idées des
bonnes pratiques qui peuvent être étendu
à notre à notre territoire pas seulement
à destination du secteur privé mais
également à destination de nos propres
nos propres administrations où il faut
qu'on soit extrêmement vigilant à ce à
ce point-là 3è 3è
proposition pour lutter contre les
stupéfiants on a besoin
on a besoin des informateurs on doit
travailler avec des informateurs
aujourd'hui le statut des informateurs
le statut des traitants de ces
informateurs n'est pas encadré on a de
vrais risques juridiques pour les
traitants de sources et je pense qu'il
faut qu'on réfléchisse au statut que
l'on souhaite donner au traitant à
l'informateur pour sécuriser
juridiquement l'intervention des
policiers des policiers traitants 4e 4e
et dernier dernier point de mon
propos protéger du contradictoire
l'utilisation de certaines techniques
spéciales d'enquête aujourd'hui
vous quand vous faites le constat qu'il
y a très très peu de recours à la
procédure d'infiltration en matière de
trafic de stupéfiants c'est la raison la
première raison de ces de cette absence
de recours c'est le fait que quand vous
vous retranscrivez intégralement en
procédures tout ce que vous mettez en
œuvre qui ensuite versé bien sûr au
contradictoire vous donnez des clés vous
donner des clés aux organisations
criminelles qui sont en face et qui vont
bien sûr chercher des vis de procédure
vous l'avez aborderé au cours de
l'audition du directeur général mais
vont aussi comprendre les méthodes que
vous mettez en place et en permanence il
faudra s'adapter mais le plus gros
risque que j'identifie c'est celui de la
mise en danger de la vie de de la
personne infiltrée donc tous ces tous
ces pointsl je pense que ça doit être
des pistes de réflexion
euh ce que ce que je voudrais dire pour
en conclusion c'est que et je vous l'ai
dit tout à l'heure à la fois il faut
qu'on soit lucide et le directeur
général vous l'a dit
euh le les la lutte contre les trafics
c'est euh un chantier énorme qui doit
mobiliser un grand nombre d'acteurs le
maître m ça doit être la coordination de
ces acteurs agir sur tous les leviers
qui sont les notres bien sûr au
ministère de l'intérieur mais pas
exclusivement et il y a beaucoup
d'autres acteurs qui qui jouent leur
rôle en la
matière il faut être humble aussi
puisqu'on a face à nous des
organisations criminelles qui ont des
puissances financières extrêmement
importantes qui s'implantent de manière
opportuniste à l'étranger là où la
coopération est pas encore toujours
optimale et nous notre rôle le rôle des
services
c'est de continuer à s'adapter de
continuer à faire progresser nos
méthodes puisque les méthodes elles
progressent quotidiennement on l'a vu en
4 ans beaucoup de choses ont été mises
en place mais c'est pas suffisant il
faut encore aller au-delà
et et donc voilà voilà les éléments que
je souhaitais porter à votre
connaissance à titre liminire et bien
sûr je suis disposé à répondre à vos
questions
merci on va entamer une une une série de
questions juste avant de donner la
parole à notre rapporteur Étienne blanc
vous avez beaucoup parlé de
renseignement quelle est quelle est la
l'articulation du travail de
renseignement avec DGSE DGSI comment ça
ça s'articule
euh et puis j'avais une question très
très accessoire par rapport à l'ensemble
du propos mais vous parlez beaucoup de
corruption et c'est un sujet qui est
central et qui
revient chez tous nos
interlocuteurs existe-t-il chez les
agents public une
corruption subie comme ça peutêtre chez
des dockerss sous menace est-ce que
c'est des des exemples qu'on a déjà eu
ou est-ce que c'est que que que un
intéressement un gain un recrutement
voilà sur la partie articulation avec
les services de renseignement ce que je
vous indiqué dans mon propos introductif
c'est que je pourrais pas développer
dans le cadre d'une d'une audition
publique les les relations qu'on
entretient avec ces ces services de
renseignement en revanche la dimension
renseignement du la lutte contre les
trafic est extrêmement importante et
doit être beaucoup plus développée
qu'elle n'a pu l'être qu'elle n pu
l'être par le passé s'agissant de la
corruption on a toutes les situations
existent en fait ça peut être de la
corruption subie avec des menaces envers
l'environnement d'un d'un agent public à
avec un gain identifié avec tout un tas
de tout un tas de leviers en fait
qu'utilisent les organisation criminelle
mais bien sûr ça peut être une
corruption subie liée à à
l'identification de membres de la
famille ou notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux enfin c'est c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure de de
l'anonymisation dans les procédures on
peut
anonymiser le l'identité des des des
policiers ou des gendarmes dans les dans
les procédures
judiciire moi j'incite les agents les
agents de l'ofaste à avoir recours à ce
à ce dispositif qui est prévu par la loi
maintenant depuis depuis plusieurs
années alors c'était pas forcément
quelque chose de de courant mais c'est
de plus en plus utilisé notamment dans
les dossiers de de très grande envergure
oui une question madame directrice merci
de cette présentation générale
et vous avez
mentionné l'efficacité de l'entrisme
dans des réseaux de
narcotrafic par des personnes infiltrées
qui sont des repentis ou des
collaborateurs de
justice la loi de 2004 av fait l'objet
de discussion très très vive lorsque ce
dispositif a été créé celle de 2013
aussi qui a amélioré et perfectionné
et mais ce principe là il se heurte à la
question du contradictoire et vous
l'avez très bien dit avec un bon
logiciel qui reprend le dossier
et
les réseaux peuvent assez facilement
identifier le repenti ou le
collaborateur de justice il y a un
principe qui est le principe du
contradictoire à partir du moment où le
dossier est devant un jus toutes les
pièces doivent lu être soumis je crois
que vous l'avez parfaitement exprimé
comment dans d'autres pays d'Europe on a
réglé cette question est-ce que selon
vous il y a des solutions pour qu'en
droit français on arrive à mieux
protéger les personnes infiltrées et les
et les repentis pour être clair est-ce
que c'est pas un peu désespérant on
regarde les principes généraux du droit
français protégés par le Conseil
constitutionnel et est-ce qu'en fait il
y a des
solutions simplement si tu me Perm parce
que c'est la même question que je
voulais et simplement ajouter est-ce que
le système italien n'est pas aujourd'hui
le meilleur système aujourd'hui au sujet
des des repentis est-ce qu' doit s'en
je vous propose je vous propose qu'on
vous fasse une réponse en en en deux à
deux voix si si c'est possible euh alors
sur dans mon propos j'ai évoqué d'abord
le sujet des sources qui est un autre
sujet des informateurs où là on est on
est sur un autre sur un autre dispositif
euh effectivement le verser au
contradictoire un certain nombre de de
d'éléments du dossier je parlait
notamment des infiltrations euh ce qui
est encore différent du du dispositif
des repentis mais ça pose ça pose des
difficultés alors le principe du
contradictoire il est pas question de le
remettre en cause parce que ça de toute
façon c'est impératif et tout doit être
exercé sous le contrôle d'un d'un
magistrat du siège et il y a pas de il
n'y a pas de de de discussion possible à
ce sujet des exemples étranger on avait
à l'époque de la loi géolocalisation
beaucoup travaillé sur l'exemple belge
notamment qui permet d'écarter certaines
dispositions du contradictoire en
matière de géolocalisation
euh la loi française l'a permis et il y
a eu une réserve du Conseil
constitutionnel qui a été qui avait été
euh
réalisé mais je pense qu'en en terme
juridique il y a il y a quand même des
voies à explorer au regard des
l'évolution des menaces et puis de
l'équilibre des des principes
constitutionnels de toute façon mais euh
mais à mon sens euh c'est exploitable
monsieur le Président Monsieur
sateur le le sujet est pas tellement de
l'identité de l'arent infiltré qui
pourrait être révélé mais c'est aussi
plus largement euh les modes opératoires
qui sont employés par la police
judiciaire pour insérer un agent dans
une organisation criminelle donc bien
sûr qu'on a besoin de de de
contradictoire la proposition c'est pas
de de que la police garde secret c'est
cela mais ça avoir un dossier à part qui
serait communiqué à l'autorité
judiciaire et l'autorité judiciaire
vérifie que on n'a pas été déloyal dans
pour obtenir des preuves mais et ça
existe effectivement d'autres pays
c'està-dire que ces élémentsl sont
communiqués à la justice mais sont pas
communiqués
à au à la défense aux organisations
criminelles en fait c'est ça le sujet
est-ce que on doit se désarmer en
communiquant nos façons de faire nos
techniques en les communiquant aux
organisations criminelles c'est ça sujet
en
fait et qui va se rattraper merci
monsieur le
Président merci Madame pour ces
monsieurs pour ces euh ce préambule très
très intéressant j'aurais deux questions
la première euh on nous dit que euh
depuis enfin l'après madouro au
Venezuela euh a vu a permis de de voir
euh arrivé les molas on nous dit que ça
d'ailleurs ça le nouveau royaume des
Molas iraniens se trouve au Venezuela
d'où de nouvelles routes
d'approvisionnement de la drogue est-ce
que on on doit attacher de l'importance
à cette information là ou oou est-ce
qu'elle est erronée et ensuite sur le
renseignement
[Musique]
euh c'est le plus vieux métier du monde
ça certains pensent peut-être à un autre
métier mais il fallait bien se procurer
les les bonnes informations et
et on a compris la nécessité d'avoir
l'information préalable pour plus
d'efficacité dans dans dans vos missions
alors cette information on peut se la
procurer de plus en plus par moyen
technique par le biais de la
manipulation vous faisz allusion au
prisonniers
manipulation consciente ou ou
inconsciente et puis il y a tout
l'aspect
infiltration des réseaux de trafiquant
et là on parle au-delà de ce qui est été
abordé jusqu'à présent on parle aussi
d'identité
fictive pour protéger les les
agents leur famille il faut bien mettre
une barrière entre leur vie réelle et la
vie qu'ils vont avoir le temps de la
mission et là il m'apparaît dites-moi si
je me trompe que dans certains pays on
sait gérer des situations qu'on ne gère
pas encore très bien en France parce que
l'administration classique ne comprend
pas toujours la nécessité de faire les
choses par exemple exemple aux
États-Unis un un
agent la CIA par exemple ou de la la NSA
peut être affecté pendant 4 ans dans une
entreprise américaine à l'étranger faire
du renseignement pendant ce temps-là sa
carrière administrative continue à se
dérouler il n'a pas de perte en
terme professionnel et il réintègre sa
fonction dans au sein de
l'administration lorsque sa sa mission
est terminée on a un autre sujet c'est
qu'en France par exemple lorsque les
agents travaillent sous identité fictive
euh lorsqu'il y a un accident grave un
rapatriment une hospitalisation voire
même parfois un décès
euh c'est pas la personne réelle qui est
décédé ou qui a été accidenté c'est son
identité fictive d'où la nécessité
vraisemblablement pour plus d'efficacité
dans ces mission là et pour une
meilleure protection des agents et de
leur familles de réfléchir à la manière
d'améliorer ces choses j'imagine que
vous avez des pistes sur cette question
là et peut-être qu'on pourrait être
utile dans ce cadre là que cette mission
pourrait être utile pour travailler à
des pistes qui permettrai plus une
meilleure protection et certainement une
meilleure efficacité de vos agents dans
leur mission si vous voulez bien va
prendre une volée de question Marie
finera merci président alors madame je
profite de votre présence en tout cas
merci pour la présentation que vous avez
faite elle m'a apporté quand même des
choses que j'ignorais il y a des choses
que je savais pas alors moi je voulais
parler du rapport sénatorial sur le
trafic de stupéfiants provenance de la
Guyane qui avait émis le souhaet he
puisque lors de la précédente mandature
il y avait une mission
d'information je crois menée par Olivier
sigoletti et dont Antoine Caram était
était le rapporteur et donc qui guyanais
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle je je
suis très à l'aise pour pour parler de
narcotrafic et dans ce rapport donc les
les collègues regrettaient que l'ofast
en Guyane particulièrement était trop
centré sur le traitement quantitatif des
passeurs alors ma question est simple
pouvez-vous nous dire si aujourd'hui le
démantelllement des réseaux figure
encore parmi vos priorités voilà merci
Olivier gadiic
oui euh il y a quelque chose qui qui
marque pas mal les gens c'est les mules
évidemment on en a parlé tout à l'heure
et euh la réponse pénale et je crois que
j'ai compris du directeur qu'il pensait
durcir éventuellement la la réponse
pénale euh par exemple au Brésil une
mule va être condamnée et va exécuter 50
prisons euh d'autres pays on les renvoie
euh en France quelle est euh la quelles
sont les peines réellement euh
prononcées euh contre les mules quand
elles sont arrêtées à rissie
euh il y a un sujet dont on parle peu et
pourtant euh s'il y a bien une problème
problmatique que partagent tous les
parents c'est que aucun d'entre eux ne
voudrait que leurs enfants se droguent
et l'enjeu je pense c'est aussi de
sanctuariser l'école comment protéger
les enfants qui sont une cible facile et
on voit que les recrutements se font de
plus en plus jeunes comment est-ce
est-ce qu'il y a un plan prévu sur ce
sur sur cette cible en particulier il y
a un modèle à Singapour semble-t-il qui
ne qui on ne constate plus du tout de
consommation d'opium j'aais savoir
d'après vous comment est-ce qu'ils ont
réussi et puis enfin puisque mon
collègue parle d'identité fictive lors
d'un décès ce sont bien les empreintes
qui garantissent l'identité d'une
personne au Brésil dès que l'on fait ces
papiers d'identité à 18 ans on prend des
empreintes de tout le monde des
empreintes digitales de deux
doigts plutôt que des papiers d'identité
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas justement
créer une identité numérique et pour
lutter contre les traf quant ne
pensez-vous pas qu'on doit s'orienter et
qui serait intéressant de créer cette
identité numérique
merci merci je vous en
prie merci beaucoup je vais reprendre
les les questions dans l'ordre en
essayant d'oublier aucun aucun aspect
euh s'agissant de la première question
sur les liens Venezuela Iran euh alors
c'est pas un phénomène qui a été détecté
pour l'instant nous on a beaucoup de
beaucoup de liens actuellement je dirais
de connexion avec le Venezuela
devrais-je dire sur des sujets
judiciaires lourd notamment sur de
l'importation de l'importation de
cocaïne euh avec
des des trafiquants français qui qui
sont qui sont implantés qui sont
implantés là-bas en terme d'analyse on n
pas du tout identifier de de de
phénomènes en lien avec l'Iran euh en
revanche ça ça sera un point d'attention
que que l'on portera et notamment que
que les équipes d'analystes de de
l'offaste se chargeront se chargeront
d'observer mais mais pour enfin sur ce
sur ce point-là j'ai pas de j'ai pas
d'élément d'éléments complémentaire à
vous à vous apporter sur le la deuxième
partie de votre question on était plus
sur le sur le renseignement alors vous
avez parlé en également dans dans votre
question de de d'infilt alors en
renseignement l'ofast ne sera pas appelé
à à conduire des missions d'infiltration
toutes ces infiltrations elles sont
réalisé bien sûr dans un cadre
judiciaire sous l'autorité sous
l'autorité d'un
magistrat ce dispositif de
l'infiltration aujourd'hui le dispositif
juridique français est complet il y a
également un travail très très important
qui est conduit par le service
interministériel d'assistance technique
qui porte les sujets et et apporte un
appui très très lourd au service dès
lors que nous nous sollicitons ce type
ce type
d'investigation vous donniez comme comme
exemple les les États-Unis bien
évidemment la France est en lien avec
son homologue aux États-Unis qui est la
DEA puisque là encore il y a énormément
de de de bonnes pratique à à aller
chercher même si il faut être
extrêmement vigilant les les régimes
juridiques sont très différents et on ne
peut pas transposer parfaitement en
France ce qui est fait ce qui est fait
aux États-Unis pour pour autant on peut
s'inspirer de de ce qui est fait et
faire évoluer les dispositifs en ce
sens donc sur sur ce point je je pense
avoir répondu répondu à votre à votre
question sur votre question madame pour
la la Guyane donc sur le traitement
qualité tif plutôt que quantitatif on a
eu des renforts qui ont été qui ont été
envoyés à l'antenne au fast de de
Guyane dans le courant de l'année 2020
enfin fin d'année 2022 et courant
courant 2023 d'autres arrivent là au
mois de en fin d'année 2000 2023
l'objectif bien évidemment quand on a
des OPJ à compéten nationales les
officiers de police judiciaire à
compétenence nationale ce n'est pas
seulement de traiter le phénomène des
mules bien sûr il faut le traiter et les
antennes les équipes de l'antenne de
l'antenne auaste guyan sont là sont là
pour ça
euh mais on doit également avoir du
temps enquêteur pour conduire des
enquêtes sous l'autorité de la JIRS de
Fort de France notamment ou sous
l'autorité de la la junalco parce que
traiter le phénomène des mules
simplement par l'interception de
passeurs c'est parfaitement insuffisant
pour démanteler un réseau et ce n'est
que le travail judiciaire en profonde
qui permettra d'attaquer les les
organisations les organisations
criminelles donc on a eu des renforts
qui ont été apportés en Guyane d'autres
également en Martinique nous sommes
évidemment extrêmement attentifs au
phénomène en île-de-fance puisque nous
DISP nous disposons sur les emprises
aéroportuaires de de roissi et d'Orly
d'équipe de l'ofast qui sont là aussi
pour traiter le le le le flux des de ces
passeurs et puis au-delà de ça les les
organ ortion criminelles qui sont qui
sont derrière et sur la brigade des
plateformes aéroportuaires he qui qui
regroupe Orli et roissi pour l'oface
nous avons un peu plus d'une trentaine
de personnes qui sont chargées du
traitement de ce ce flux là alors bien
sûr l'face c'est pas le seul acteur à
travailler sur sur ce phénomène vous
avez les services de la préfecture de
police et puis la douane qui aujourd'hui
fait du traitement simplifié puisqueen
fonction de la quantité
de la quantité
transportée vous aurez une procédure
simplifiée qui sera mise en œuvre bien
sûr sous sous l'autorité du procureur de
la République et c'est le protocole
notamment qui a été décliné décliné par
le procureur de la République de de
créteille sur la réponse pénale
peut-être Christian droini sera plus
légitime à vous répondre sur une
question qui est plus judiciaire
oui sur la réponse pénale la la la voie
procédurale qui éta en général employé
tant à Cayenne à bobini et qu' créteille
c'est la voix de la comparution
immédiate c'est-à-dire la réponse
relativement rapide sauf lorsqu'on a dès
l'enquête en fait des perspectives pour
travailler sur un démandement d'une
organisation criminelle sur a des
éléments pour pour aller vraiment plus
profondément en fait dans les
investigations la peine
après c'est c'est ce compte en plutôt en
années de prison c'est plutôt de cet
ordre làà suivant la quantité parfois
mais je je le dis entre nous euh parfois
on dit UNE une année par kilo quelque
chose comme ça mais c'est vraiment très
c'est pour donner une idée mais pas plus
que ça parce que il y a des il y a des
personnalisations qui sont faites par
les par les juges du siège par la par le
tribunal
correctionnel merci il y avait une
dernière question sur l'école donc la
sanctuarisation de l'école alors il y a
déjà beaucoup d'intervention de
policiers de de gendarmes sur la
préventif et la sensibilisation des
élèves à l'usage à l'usage des des
drogues on a on a
également initié l'année dernière un
partenariat avec l'Éducation nationale
dans le cadre du fonctionnement des
cellules de renseignement opérationnel
sur les stupéfiants les cross qui sont
des instances de partage de
renseignement et on a souhaité se
rapprocher aussi de l'éducation
nationale de manière à pouvoir euh
intervenir au titre de de renseignement
que l'éducation nationale
souhaiterait signaler sur des euh à la
fois des points de vente ou même des
situations des situations complexes
autour d'un trafique autour autour de
l'école ça reste pour l'instant au stade
assez embryonnaire mais ce sont des des
initiatives à développer le modèle de
Singapour je ne le connais pas il sera
intéressant qu'on le qu'on examine
effectivement pour en tirer des des
enseignements Roger
KCI posait la question tout à l'heure de
la légalisation du cannabis est-ce qu'il
faut
traiter cette lutte contre les
stupéfiants de manière
uniforme c'est un débat qui qui assez
présent dans notre société est-ce que il
y a des moyens qui peuê dégagés sur les
drogues les plus agressives les plus
dures quel est votre avis sur le
sujet
alors sur la légalisation du cannabis
puisque c'est ce produit dont dont il
est
question la France s'est engagée sur un
maintien de la pénalisation de l'usage
avec la mise en place de l'amende
forfaitaire délictuelle
2022 ce sont 143000 amendes forfaitaires
délictuelles qui ont été prononcé les
exemples étrangers puisque nous en avons
aujourd'hui un certain nombre nous
montre
que la légalisation n'assèche pas le
marché met en place un marché parallèle
au marché légal et surtout on le voit
sur les études sur sur l'usage on a des
consommateurs qui aujourd'hui
s'orientent vers des produits de plus en
plus toxiques il est clair que les
produits qui seront proposés qui
seraient proposés sur un marché légal ne
seront pas nécessairement ceux avec un
niveau de toxicité attendu par les
attendu par les usagers
et donc le le
risque d'avoir un un second marché qui
serait le marché noir des
trafics pour se poursuivrait de toute
façon donc sur la
légalisation il ne semble pas que ce
soit une une la solution à
l'éradication de de ces trafics d'autant
plus que je vous le disais en
introduction on a des consommateurs qui
se tournent de plus en plus vers des
drogues de synthèse et vers des produits
extrêmement
nocif je me tourne vers mes collègues
pour savoir Karine Daniel moi j'avais
une question vous avez évoqué le le
sujet qui fait l'objet de beaucoup de de
crispation de la part des des de nos
concitoyens des points de d'Al vous
avveit dit qu'on recense mieux les les
points de Deal ce qui est mais mais ce
qui est attendu c'est derrière comment
est-ce qu'on traite ce sujet qui est
très localisé qui génère derrière
évidemment les les fait de on en a parlé
encore à Dijon ce weekend les les faits
de pardon de tir arme à feu notamment
euh comment vous traitez ces ces sujets
parce que les réponses qui nous sont
données sur le sur le terrain c'est
souvent finalement on on on laisse un
peu patienter et et on laisse se
dérouler le trafic sur ces points de
deal en nous disant qu'on mène des
investigations derrière mais cette cette
cette réponse apparaît pas
très satisfaisante pour pour les
citoyens dans les quartiers souvent les
plus difficiles dans lesquels on a ces
ces points de
Deal alors sur les sur les points de
deal
en janvier 2021 on a enfin fin d'année
2020 et début d'année 2021 on a procédé
à un recensement le premier exercice ça
a été de procéder à un recenscement de
l'ensemble des points d'î présent sur le
territoire sur le territoire national
avec ensuite parce qu'une fois qu'on les
a recensé c'est parfaitement insuffisant
c'est quelle action on conduit sur ces
sur ces points de d' il y a des actions
de plusieurs niveau qui sont qui sont
conduites il y a bien
sûr des opérations de voie publique qui
permettent des interventions des
interventions
policières de terrain mais qui
permettent pas d'éradiquer là en
profondeur le le le point en lui-même
qui va qui a beaucoup de chance de se
réinstaller dans le hall d' côté ou ou
qui va attendre quelques jours et puis
qui va qui va se réimplanter dès lors
que que les patrouilles de police seront
parties donc en revanche il a un travail
plus en profondeur qui nécessite là
encore des enquêtes judiciaires qui
prennent un peu plus de temps
effectivement que la l'opération de voie
publique mais qui permett d'attaquer
plus en profondeur le le point en
lui-même
euh on recense chaque mois toutes les
opérations qui sont conduites sur chacun
de ces points de de censé de manière à
avoir aussi une je dirais une régularité
des acteurs c'est-à-dire une persistance
de l'action qui est conduite c'est pas
parce que on a conduit en janvier une
opération sur tel point de Deal que
quelques semaines plus tard ou quelques
jours plus tard on doit pas y retourner
et c'est vrai que on on a ce travail de
recensement qui qui est comptabilisé au
niveau de l'oface à travers C ce nouvel
outil cartofaste qu'on qu'on a créé en
qui a été mis en place en en juin 2000
in 2022 donc qui permet à la fois de
suivre l'activité l'activité des
services donc les opérations qui sont
conduites l'effet réel sur les points de
d'Ille et on le voit un certain nombre
depuis la mise en place de de cette
cartographie ont disparu euh alors là
encore certains sont en sommeil d'autres
ont réellement disparu mais c'est la
persistance de l'action en fait qui est
qui est extrêmement importante et le
renouvellement le renouvellement dans le
temps le tout couronné par des des
enquêtes judiciaires qui vont permettre
effectivement d'avoir un effet à long
terme d'avoir un effet sur sur le
démantèement des structures qui tiennent
ces points
deil je m'autorise une question qui qui
met en perspective cette audition de
celle que nous avions eu devant la
commission des lois qui est un autre
cadre euh c'est peut-être parce que je
suis déniaisé sur le sujet mais j'avais
trouvé votre intervention à peu près
avec le même contenu assez alarmiste et
qui ça m'avait un peu mobilisé comme
comme parlementaire et je trouve
aujourd'hui que le ton est celui d'un
dispositif assez bouclé finalement alors
il y a bien quelques demandes mais bon
pas de demande de moyens donc je
visiblement tout tourne peu de demande
législatives est-ce que je me trompe
ou on va sortir finalement rassuré alors
qu'on est entré dans cette mission en se
disant qu'il y avait submersion du
produit que c'était quand même un de on
a un peu le sentiment que tous les
territoires s'inquiètent et et et la
tonalité mais je peux me tromper c'est
mon oreille qui doit euh me faire des me
jouer des tours est assez posé et
presque tranquille est-ce que je me
trompe alors le je crois que la menace
l'état de la menace parle de lui-même le
je dirais le les enjeux sont aujourd'hui
très très important enfin
effectivement pas de demande d'effectif
parce que je pense pas que ce soit le
lieu pour demander des effectifs et ça
fait partie de de dialogue que l'on a
avec le directeur général et je crois
que sur la mise en place du dispositif
euh moi je suis arrivée à l'ofaste en
préfiguration en septembre 2019 avec un
effectif de 80 personnes chargées de la
lutte contre les stupéfiants au niveau
central on est passé aujourd'hui à 220
avec une diversification des profils
donc euh les l'engagement que ce soit du
ministère de l'intérieur ou de ses
partenaires en terme de de structuration
du dispositif et réel euh alors ça veut
pas dire que il est suffisant mais ça
veut dire que on a mis en place un
certain nombre de choses et qu'il faut
aujourd'hui au-delà d'un d'un apport
rche pur bien mettre en place et
consolider toute la méthode qui a été
définie puisque je pense que la lutte
contre les trafics de stupéfiants elle
passe aussi par une méthode elle passe
pas que par des apport rage si si vous
ne faites que de l'apport rage dans un
service et que vous n'avez pas de
stratégie vous n'aurez pas de résultats
il est extrêmement important aujourd'hui
vous avez c'est ce que je vous disais en
introduction vous avez beaucoup de
services qui luttent contre les trafics
de stupéfiants que ce
soit au sein de la police nationale au
sein de la gendarmerie tous à leur
niveau mais il faut que chacun le fasse
à son niveau et de manière coordonné en
agissant suivant une doctrine
suivant un plan aussi parce que le le
rôle du chef de fil c'est porter un plan
de porter des mesures qui sont qui sont
phares et Orient
sur les grandes
priorités donc les moyens on en a
toujours besoin bien évidemment mais je
crois
qu'aujourd'hui le dispositif montre que
les engagements pris ont été ont été
tenu on adapte le dispositif dans les
territoires on a une aujourd'hui on a un
détachement au Avre en 2021 on a créé un
détachement au fast au Havre ce
détachement euh il s'avère insuffisant
on avait
ETP h policiers chargés de lutter contre
les trafics de stupéfiants au avrees
alors l'offast central projette très
souvent de manière hebdomadaire
quasiment des effectifs sur l'antenne du
Havre sur le détachement du Havre
néanmoins ce dispositif nous est paru
insuffisant pourquoi parce qu'on avait
que le volet judiciaire opérationnel il
manquait la dimension renseignement il
manquait la dimension analyse et donc
cette antenne ce détachement on le
transforme en antenne de plein exercice
à compter de la fin de l'année 2023 avec
un apport RH extrêmement important pour
je dirais avoir un traitement immédiat
du phénomène sur sur le secteur
après les mesures législatives d'ordre
législatif je vous en ai je vous en ai
listé quatre mais l'idée n'était pas de
faire une liste à la prévre de de toute
de T tous nos besoins non plus euh
néanmoins il y a beaucoup de choses à
faire évoluer on a on a parlé de la
corruption mais pas des avoirs criminels
alors qu'il y a énormément de choses à
qui pourrai également progresser sur
cette sur cette matière-là aujourd'hui
ce sont les saisies réalisées en matière
de trafic de stupéfiants les saisies
d'avoir criminels représente 13 % du
total des avoirs criminels saisis on
parle du premier marché criminel au
monde ça veut dire qu'on a des marges de
progression en terme de saisie et tout
n'est pas de niveau législatif on a
aussi des enjeux en en terme de
formation avec nos personnels euh à à à
mettre en œuvre alors on parle de la
police et de la gendarmerie parce qu'on
est au ministère de l'intérieur mais euh
du côté de la magistrature c'est
également quelque chose une
sensibilisation des magistrats également
nécessaire euh on a aujourd'hui
l'agence la grasque qui est l'agence de
gestion qui a été créée maintenant il y
a quelques années qui est euh une
structure essentielle pour progresser en
matière de saisie et de confiscation
parce qu'une fois que la saisie est
réalisée c'est pas suffisant il faut
aller au stade de la confiscation en
phase de jugement on a toute cette
impulsion à donner à un niveau politique
avec le ministère des Affaires
étrangères sur la coopération
internationale donc les chantiers ils
sont extrêmement vastes et l'ambition
elle est elle est toujours très forte
sur ce
sujet-là vous rassure est-ce que le
rapporteur est satisfait à ce stade
mesdames et messieurs les membres de la
commissionok
bien merci
beaucoup des questions n vient sur le
JO très bien merci
beaucoup